sinue place aux matchs des idées
maintenant confrontation de points de
vue ce soir entre romain goupil et
florent vadillo on va revenir sur le
projet de loi climat a présenté en
conseil des ministres ce matin le texte
contient une soixantaine d'articles il
reprend environ la moitié des
propositions de la convention citoyenne
mais on est loin des 100 % et surtout on
est loin du sans fil être qu avait
promis emmanuel macron ce qui provoque
pas mal de déception va y revenir avec
nos invités d'abord le texte le texte
avec jordan plein réduire de 40% les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre d'ici
c'est l'objectif du gouvernement est ce
projet de loi climat y participent
ce texte présenté ce mercredi en conseil
des ministres a pour vocation de toucher
à tous les aspects de la vie des
français de la consommation au
déplacement au passant par
l'alimentation ou le logement
cette loi en fait c'est une loi qui va
faire entrer l'écologie est donc le bon
sens dans la vie quotidienne des
français et les le bon sens pourquoi
parce que c'est deux choses on va
arrêter le grand n'importe quoi sur un
certain nombre de sujets et on va aussi
donner des solutions pratiques aux
français ce projet de loi puis ses idées
dans la convention climat sur les 149
proposition qu'ont fait les citoyens
seuls 46 ont été retenue par le
gouvernement pour un total de 65 article
parmi les propositions phares
l'interdiction des vols intérieurs quand
une alternative entre un de moins de
deux heures existe la fin des publicités
pour les énergies fossiles
l'interdiction de la vente des véhicules
thermiques les plus pollueurs en 2030 ou
encore la fin de la location des
passoires thermiques en 2028
c'est une grande occasion ratée à le
président de la république fait le choix
de protéger ses amis en fait un les
publicitaires les géants de l'aviation
les
géant américain moi ce que je propose
dans la plate forme d'idées que j'ai
sorti c'est que pour les passoires
énergétiques et les ménages les plus
vulnérables
laval y ait une prise en charge totale
de la rénovation thermique pour
accélérer la rénovation thermique créer
de l'emploi l'artisan état ou par les
propriétaires par l'état le gouvernement
qui a enclenché une procédure accélérée
pour l'examen de ce texte table sur un
vote définitif d'ici l'été ou la rentrée
avec nous pour le match des idées ce
soir romain goupil bienvenue vous êtes
réalisateur florent vadillo bienvenue
président du think tank letteri ancien
conseiller spécial de jean jacques
urvoas et co auteur de ce livre
les espions de l'elysée le président et
les services de renseignements sur ce
texte climat c'est assez difficile de se
faire un avis je vous le cache pas on a
les écologistes les citoyens de la
convention qui se disent très déçus
certains parlent même d'un texte vide
c'est ce qu'on pouvait lire aujourd'hui
notamment sur les réseaux sociaux et en
même temps on a du mal à imaginer que 65
articles de ce projet lensois vide vous
avez réussi à vous faire un avis une
opinion florent radio
je pense que le gouvernement en fait
emmanuel macron en particulier s'est mis
dans une chausse trappe dès l'origine
parce qu en externalisant en quelque
sorte la respectabilité de son futur
texte
il était contraint de soi tout prendre
soit d'accepter d'être en fait l'homme
des renoncements et même de renoncement
aurait été de trop médiatiquement il ne
pouvait pas tenir la charge donc je
crois qu'il avait perdu le combat
médiatique d'avant ce sauf à tout
prendre il ya 65 mesures de ce texte ça
va dans le bon sens je suis à un moment
donné il faut accepter de dire que ça
sera toujours 65 mesures de plus et
c'est nécessaire néanmoins on est obligé
de voir l'écart à ce qui nécessite de
faire et aujourd'hui nous sommes on ne
peut pas nous répéter à longueur de
journée que nous sommes gens s'il ya une
urgence que nous avons cinq années pour
agir dix années pour agir pour les plus
optimistes et voir qu on est encore à
des dispositions qui sont des
accommodements non raisonnable
et de ce fait ce qui a été fait avant ce
texte là on est assez éloquent sur les
néonicotinoïdes sur la montagne d'or etc
donc je crois qu'il y a besoin d'une
plus grande ambition et mais pour le
coup je pense que tout gouvernement
confronté à la même situation n'aurait
pas fait aussi bien
et n'aurait pas fait mieux en quelle que
soit donc la situation exigerait plus je
crois que politiquement ce qui est sur
la table déjà pas mal d'autant que le
texte se présente au parlement et que le
jeu du parlement fera que ce texte sera
amendée améliorer donc in fine et je
pense qu'on sera pas sur une catastrophe
absolue
on sera en dessous de ce qui est
nécessaire romain goupil comment vous
vous les voyez ces réactions qui parfois
sont un peu caricatural en disant ce
texte et vit malheureusement on n'est
pas en période de proportionnelle donc
chacun doit se défendre par rapport à
des échéances qui vont arriver et là
c'est la surenchère ça ne suffit pas ça
ne suffit pas ça ne suffira jamais passé
aussi ça suffisait ben on dissout est
élevée on renonce à une candidature de
monsieur jadot ou même socialo écolo du
ps
et voilà c'est réglé dans tous les cas
de figure il faut dire que ça ne va pas
mais ça ne va pas ce bizarre ce ne ne va
pas elle est plutôt dans le bon sens
bien sûr qu'il faut améliorer ses 65
propositions sur les 147 où les 150 qui
était proposée même s'il ya les trois
jokers elle n'existait pas avant
elle n'existait pas sous le gouvernement
précédent
c'est 65 chose de plus et comme vous
l'avez exactement mais souligné c'est ce
n'est pas un parlement c'est une
convention citoyenne
ils ont fait des propositions
propositions peut-être que ils ont
imaginé parce qu'ils ont été bien
traités qui remplaçait les élus qu'ils
emprunt c'est le sénat qui remplaçait
même la présidence de la république
parce que il disait ça ça avait force de
loi il devait participer le président
parfait en passant si c'est rare fait
est ce qui s'est passé au moment dé
gilet jaune il en a tiré la leçon en
imposant le gouvernement cette taxe de 6
centimes sur le plein d'essence ça a mis
en place dès gilet jaune 400000 gens qui
ont protesté en disant on n'est pas les
vaches à lait on veut pas être les
victimes de paris arrêté nous imposer
des 80 km heure
on met en place une discussion de
citoyens qui sont tirés au sort et ont
fait des propositions et après à
l'assemblée nationale au sénat à la
présidence au conseil des ministres qui
va être fait demain de discuter pour moi
c'est effectivement un petit pas mais le
petit pas c'est mieux que pas mais aucun
soin vous avez entendu comme moi même
nicolas hulot qui a priori n'est pas
dans la posture politicienne sur tmc
hier soir dans quotidien nous dit je ne
pensais pas qu'il faudrait prendre 30
ans pour arriver à un résultat aussi
modeste voilà ce qu'il dit je ne dis pas
que le gouvernement ne fait rien je ne
tombe pas dans cet excellent a dit il la
question n'est pas de savoir si ce qu'on
fait est bien
mais est ce qu'on en fait suffisamment
pour tenir nos engagements
la réponse est non fin de citation il
pas dans la posture nicolas n'est pas
grave si elle est pire que ça il a fait
un film où c'était la fin du monde je
sais même plus comment ça s'appelait un
truc cataclysmique où il y montrait des
images de drones ou ça y est on allait
tous mourir demain c'est à dire à la
sortie de la projection si vous faisait
rien pour climat on était mort il était
ministre ne l'at il pas dit quand il
était ministre que simplement de dire je
ne peux pas mais je ne peux pas être pas
l'attitude à avoir par rapport à ce qui
menace mais pas la france
ce qui menace qui nous menacent au
niveau du monde je trouve
qu'effectivement sauf alors à jupiter
plus plus plus c'est à dire je suis
maître du monde et j'impose comme ça à
la chine j'impose à monsieur trump à
l'époque une réduction des gaz à effet
de serre on a va dans une direction on
est à l'initiative de
la coop 21 on essaye d'avancer avec les
citoyens mais citoyens sont déçus parce
que ça va pas assez vite demander haut
débit s'ils sont déçus ou à la publicité
s'ils sont déçus ça va trop vite pour on
est en train de mettre la chasse sont
bousculés donc c'est comme ça la société
fonctionne comme ça mais je pense que le
fait que y ait des élus qu'ils puissent
faire des amendements et ils vont en
faire est une excellente chose ils vont
pas se gêner sur cette question des
enjeux de politique politicienne et je
vous donne la parole juste après florent
radio europe ecologie les verts a aussi
intérêt à trouver ce projet de loi trop
peu ambitieux et c'est assez sévèrement
que françois de rugy a taclé son ancien
parti c'était ce matin sur ce plateau
sur public sénat et coûter d'expérience
évidemment qu'on peut toujours dire ça
ne va pas assez loin mais ce qui compte
c est ce qu on traite les problèmes
c'est pas les symboles
je vois bien que un certain nombre de
nos opposants et notamment europe
ecologie les verts ils vont s'agiter sur
des symboles vous dira mais telle mesure
elle n'est pas exactement ce que la
convention citoyenne a prévu europe
ecologie les verts qui étaient contre la
convention citoyenne quand nous l'avons
créée et qu'elle dit c'est une manoeuvre
pour perdre du temps et puis maintenant
qui dit attention ce qui a été proposé
par la convention citoyenne doit y être
strictement mis en oeuvre dans la loire
bon tout ça c'est de l'agitation
c'est de l'agitation florent amadio
c'est de l'agitation bien sûr c'est les
règles de la politique après ce qui est
étonnant c'est que rennes ancien
président de l'assemblée nationale
estime que le symbole n'est pas
important en politique parce que si la
politique ce n'est pas justement l'art
d'orchestrer des symboles dans le bon
sens du terme
il ya un problème bon qu'europe écologie
les verts demandent à ce que un logiciel
écologistes plus importants soient mises
en oeuvre dans le texte c'est naturel
c'est normal c'est souhaitable même mais
c'est le rôle politique d'aiguillon que
ce parti ait d'autres incarnent que
françois de rugy essayé de protéger sa
majorité enfin la majorité à laquelle il
appartient là encore c'est normal on le
fait avec plus ou moins de talent
ensuite je crois qu est ce qui est
important c'est vraiment de montrer ce
que j'évoquais à l'instant c'est l'écart
à ce qui est nécessaire
il ya aujourd'hui des mesures qu'il
manque qui sont absolument
indispensables et on voit quand même que
sur on est prompt à voir des discours
sur l'écologie du quotidien
où sont les changements radicaux sur les
consommations industriels sur la
réorientation de la politique agricole
sur bien des aspects on voit julien de
normandie qui au sénat monte pour dire
arrêtons d opposer agriculture écologie
sauf que lui même a voulu opposer
l'écologie de raison et de l'écologie
hystérique je crois à reprendre ses
termes donc en réalité il y à des
accommodements non raisonnable je le
répète qu'ils ont été réalisés qui
aujourd'hui exit les tenants de
l'écologie à juste titre donc
gageons que l'étape au parlement
permettra symboliquement d'ajouter des
choses très importantes mais encore une
fois des réorientations sont nécessaires
et on ne peut pas prendre des mesures en
demi teinte si l'on estime qu'il ya une
urgence écologique
moi je le crois deuxième thème de ce
match messieurs c'est cette annonce
d'eric dupond-moretti et d'adrien taquet
sur les crimes sexuels sur mineurs et
sur cette question du consentement
après avoir consulté nous sommes
favorables à ce que soit défini un
nouveau crime dit il c'est à dire que
tout acte de pénétration sexuelle commis
par un majeur sur un mineur de 15 ans
est un crime sans qu'il ne soit plus
question de consentement nous a dit le
secrétaire d'état à l'emploi
création d'un nouveau crime seuils d'âge
du consentement tout cela ça fait des
années que le sénat y travaillent et
quelques semaines qu'une proposition de
loi a même été adoptée à l'unanimité au
sénat
c'est votre loi annie billon je ne sais
pas si vous êtes en ligne bonsoir elle
vous êtes sénatrice union centriste de
lavande et merci d'être avec nous et
d'intervenir ponctuellement dans ce
match comme ça on a quand même à un
moment on a cru un moment je sais pas
vous que le gouvernement ne ferait pas
référence à votre travail
finalement il va intégrer ces
propositions dans votre loi c'est bien
ça écoutez fait fort moi ce que ce que
je note aujourd'hui c'est que le sénat a
voté un texte
il y a trois semaines à l'unanimité 343
votants 343 pour l'objectif qui était
recherché péter la protection des
mineurs en contournant les autres pactes
qui avait fait reculer le gouvernement
en 2018
malgré les annonces du président de la
république en 2017
j'étais effectivement contourner la
ville
négatif du conseil d'état sur une
inconstitutionnalité possible moi j'ai
travaillé à ce texte
il y à plus d'un an en me disant qu'il
était important malgré tout d'inscrire
un interdit sociale sociétale dans la
loi donc c'est ce que j'ai réussi à
faire avec le sénat en posant deux
verrous supplémentaire dans la loi
l'interdiction de relations sexuelles
avec tous mineurs en dessous de 13 ans
et en plus un deuxième verrons pour
sécuriser la criminalisation des
relations entre adultes et mineurs de
moins de 15 ans pourquoi c'est pourquoi
fait ces deux verrous pour mieux
protéger les mineurs l'objectif du
gouvernement aujourd'hui c'est le même
objectif
il semble pouvoir y arriver différemment
voilà où on en est là aujourd'hui
donc si je vous entends bien vous êtes
plutôt satisfaite que votre travail et
été reconnue est ce que quand même à un
moment donné vous ai dit que le
gouvernement allait réécrire
complètement repartir d'une page blanche
à écrire complètement sa propre loi sans
tenir compte de votre travail
écoutez depuis trois semaines moi je
suis en contact régulier avec le
gouvernement et notamment marc raynaud
qui en charge des relations avec le
parlement
nous avons voté un texte à l'unanimité
voté par la commission des lois avant
son débat en séance
ce texte qui les sécuriser juridiquement
il ne tombe pas aimer contourner les
obstacles du conseil d'état de l'époque
donc c'est une balle majeur pour pouvoir
travailler et avancer avec le
gouvernement sur un sujet sur lequel il
y a urgence donc autant s'appuyer sur
une base solide et travailler en amont
au sénat pour pouvoir avancer souris
l'objectif du gouvernement on a les
mêmes objectifs
on peut avoir des chemins différents
pour y arriver - c'est le chemin que
j'avais trouvée pour contourner ces
obstacles
si le garde des sceaux avec le ministre
adrien paquet nous propose un chemin
différent pour y arriver
bien entendu nous allons travailler
ensemble pour y arriver et pour la
protection des mineurs et koen nous
bon oui kim un objectif commun entre le
sénat et le gouvernement a ni billon je
vous propose de rester encore quelques
minutes avec nous puisque on va faire
réagir nos invités en plateau est
évidemment vous vous manifester si vous
souhaitez réagir à ce qui est dit romain
goupil finalement le gouvernement
choisit même d'aller plus loin en termes
de seuils d'âge de consentement en
allant jusqu'à 15 ans alors que ce qui
avait été voté au sénat étaient treize
ans qu'en pensez vous je pense que il là
j'ai assisté à l'interview qu'il a donné
un entretien qu'a donnée le garde des
sceaux sur france 2 hier
il disait même plus en dix ans n'est
encore ouverts à des discussions par
rapport à l'inceste avec les différentes
associations
il a ils ont tenu compte bien sûr de
tout le travail et un vote à l'unanimité
c'est n'est pas rien le travail qu'a
fait le sénat et la proposition de
annick billon qu'on dise maintenant
quelque chose de très clair mais c'est
encore plus clair pour pour pour nous si
on réfléchit sur l'inceste en disant à
aucun moment il ne peut y avoir
discussion sur le consentement par
rapport à l'inceste
à aucun moment un père peut dire par
rapport à juste oui il y avait on
laissait entendre cette idée là par
rapport aux enfants déjà ça c'est
extrêmement clair sur les réserves qui
peut y avoir elles sont contenues dans
les discussions c'est à dire en disant
ah oui mais si c'est un garçon et une
fille de 17 ans et qui rencontre un
garçon de 14 ans et demi est ce que là
on tiendra compte une fois qu'à sa
majorité
est-ce qu'il faut pas inclure un écart
d'âge c'est à dire pour éviter entre
tous ces éléments sont pris en compte
rien n'est encore réglé c'est encore
ouvert mail annonces d'hier disait
quelque chose que là on a tous compris
très clairement en dessous de 15 ans il
n'ya pas consentement et noon avancer
plus ça pour la pédocriminalité ou pour
l'un cesse comme argument ça me semble
une chose extrêmement claire par rapport
à toutes les affaires là qui qui qui qui
nous entoure annie billon on me dit que
vous souhaitez réagir et je vous laisse
la parole en sus florent radio et bien
écoutez moi jour je rejoins les propos
de de votre invité en réalité nous ce
qu'on avait souhaité faire en
contournant
l'avis du conseil d'état déposé un
interdit clair qu'ils soient pas
démonter par le conseil constitutionnel
derrière et renforcé entre 13 et 15
aujourd'hui le garde des sceaux pause
eut interdit à 15 en effet très bien
pour les victimes véritablement et
propose un régime d'exception pour les
relations consenties entre adolescents
eh bien écoutez travaillons ensemble
pour conforter ce dispositif pour qu'il
soit un outil pour condamner les
agresseurs et fait vrai que la vague de
témoignages à laquelle le on doit faire
face aujourd'hui on se doit de trouver
un chemin commun moi je préside la
délégation aux droits des femmes au
sénat ces sujets là ce ne sont pas des
sujets clivants politiquement on les
porte en général à la délégation de
manière unanime on doit pouvoir trouver
la solution juridique on va dire pour un
chien dans la loi ce qui a été proposé
et moi je me suis fait des noeuds dans
la tête pour réussir à avancer sur ce
sujet eh bien on va continuer de
travailler avec le gouvernement et c'est
c'est pour les victimes et c'est
vraiment pour protéger ces mineurs parce
que lorsqu'on fait que 1
en réalité un mineur sur dix est victime
de l'agression sexuelle
lorsqu'on sait que 80 pour 7% les
agressions sexuelles sur mineurs sont le
fait de l'entourage
on se rend bien compte qu'avec ces
dispositifs dans la loi on va réussir à
criminaliser des actifs qui doivent être
finalisées
on doit protéger les enfants on a
justement un juriste en plateau l'on va
dit oh ces juristes que j'ai envie
d'entendre sur ce point ça va passer ça
peut passer
avant l'épisode 2 que l'on est en train
de vivre
sociétal il y aurait eu un débat
constitutionnel sur le droit au procès
équitable parce que le droit pénal à des
rigueurs très importante est en fait le
conseil se serait sans doute conseil
considère ce serait sans doute exprimé
sur la capacité à l' équilibre des
droits de la défense et de l'accusation
et c'est sans doute pour cela que la
question qui pouvait y avoir des
questions qui nous paraissent
aujourd'hui odieuses mais qui sont
nécessaires pour éviter des
condamnations à tort ou des
condamnations qui serait fondée sur de
mauvaises preuve de drôle je crois
qu'aujourd'hui le droit c'est aussi la
patte du temps et je crois
qu'aujourd'hui le conseil
constitutionnel aurait plus de
difficultés au regard de l'état d'esprit
de la société pour faire cet arbitrage
précautionneux je crois qu'aujourd'hui
on est clairement sur ce sur un débat
qui a été politiquement dégagé d'autant
que la sénatrice l'a très bien dit ce
droit pénal là c'est un droit de
principe qui fixe ce qui est acceptable
socialement lévi strauss le disait sur
l'interdît de l'inceste qui est à la
fondation de nos sociétés je crois
qu'aujourd'hui en étant à une nouvelle
étape où la société montre très
clairement une prise de position qui est
qu'est ce que la modernité et la
modernité repousse de manière très
violente ce genre de comportements
déviants et donc cette loi participe à
cela et je crois que c'est une ce nouvel
équilibre des temps le conseil
constitutionnel en tiendra compte
et je ne vois pas de fragilité
constitutionnel de ce point de vue là
d'autant que les précautions seront
prises
une précaution majeur ça sera sans doute
sur l' équilibre de l'opportunité des
poursuites
plus le texte sera précis plus en
réalité il aura deux failles
donc c'est là où notamment la question
de l'écart d'âge et je pense qu'il faut
laisser à l'autorité judiciaire le soin
de qualifier ce qu'elle estime être un
crime ou pas alors que la loin à borner
sa capacité d'interprétation
jurisprudentielle
donc je serais plutôt sur le fait de
garder un texte le plus clair possible
sans précision superflu je crois que
laurence rossignol sur votre sur votre
chaîne faisait écho justement cette
nécessité d'opportunités poursuites je
crois qu'il faut s'en remettre à cela
pour la sécurisation juridique garder
une marge merci beaucoup a dit billon
d'avoir participé comme je le disais
ponctuellement à ce match des idées
merci dieu
participer ça nous amène au troisième
point de ce match c'est la démission du
directeur de sciences-po frédéric
millions suite à la sphère duhamel le
rapport pointe de ma part des erreurs de
jugement dans le traitement des
allégations dont j'avais eu
communication en 2018 ainsi que des
incohérences dans la manière dont je me
suis exprimé sur le déroulement de cette
affaire après qu'elle a éclaté
je mesure le trouble qui en résulte et
j'en assume l'entière responsabilité
voilà ce que nous dit fredericlyon avant
de démissionner un coup dur pour l'école
du pouvoir mais aussi pour le conseil
d'état dont sciences po est depuis
toujours l'une des places-fortes ça
c'est ce que nous disent les
journalistes raphaëlle bacqué et ariane
chemin du monde qui ont beaucoup suivi
cette affaire qu'en pensez vous romain
goupil
je pense que tout est contenu dans le
communiqué de frais directs lyon il
reconnaît des mensonges des erreurs des
à des approximations des mensonges
réellement il va mentir quand il fait
ces déclarations à la presse qu'on fait
ces déclarations devant les élèves
il va mentir sur les faits le travail de
raphaëlle bacqué d'ariane chemin et
remet précisément depuis quelques jours
une semaine je pense à peu près ça une
dizaine de jours très précisément les
contradictions
il n'en a tenu compte je ne suis pas
juge ne suis pas policier il a
démissionné c'est parfait comme ça
il reconnaît l'ensemble des erreurs qui
ont été pointés par ses journalistes et
d'autres journalistes ou des
chroniqueurs pour moi il n'ya pas
commentaire sauf son texte est parfait
j'ai menti je me suis trompé je me
retire
j'en tire les conséquences et après
qu'est ce qui s'est passé pourquoi
comment et qui se sent lésé
je pensais à suffisamment d'instance
pour sciences po pour que ce se soit
posé entre eux mais au-delà de ça est ce
que c'est la fin d'une omerta est ce
qu'on est en train d'assister à ce
phénomène de société dont vous parler un
petit peu tout à l'heure mais là qui se
passe dans une école du pouvoir alors je
pense que il ya deux aspects très
différent oui c'est la fin peut-être pas
d'une omerta mais en tout cas d'un
silence coupable
et pas nécessairement à sciences po on
voit que le livre de camille kouchner
est de ce point de vue là assez éloquent
parce que finalement on se rend compte
que peu de gens ne savaient pas ce qui
se passait depuis 2008 et s'est il n'y
avait pas que des diplômés de sciences
po hélas et ensuite il ya le cas de
frédéric née en moi je serais plus
[Musique]
comment dire j'aurais plus de sympathie
pour frédéric pignon dans cette histoire
parce que pour moi il a commis trois
erreurs
la première c'est qu'il a été comme tout
le monde je le crois intellectuellement
prisonnier de son milieu un milieu dans
lequel la notabilité équivaut au mieux
de la respectabilité au pire une
présomption d'innocence renforcer voire
de la tranquillité et que lorsqu'il
s'est adressé qui à jean veil qui a
marre guillaume qui l'ont rassuré lui
disant non on ne peut pas imaginer ça
d'olivier duhamel
eh bien il a parce qu'il était
prisonnier de son milieu comme tout le
monde
décidé de croire que c'était plus des
rumeurs que des faits la deuxième erreur
qu'il a commise c'était dans ce contexte
là de consignes leçon inaugurale à
olivier duhamel et je crois que c'est ça
aujourd'hui qu'on lui reproche c'est
d'avoir continué à mettre sur un
piédestal un individu sur lequel court
et des rumeurs très appuyé la troisième
erreur qu'il a commise à mes yeux c'est
d'avoir été ballotté par les événements
médiatiques et ne pas avoir préparé une
ligne de défense claire car c'est cela
finalement
il a été incohérent dans sa défense plus
qu'il n'a menti il a été incohérent il a
d'abord essayé de se protéger de
protéger son école avant de céder face à
la pression
néanmoins à sciences po disons le
l'action qui a été conduite par lui mais
par l'ensemble de l'administration sur
les faits de violence faite aux
étudiants est absolument admirable elle
est pour moi un exemple de ce qu'il faut
continuer à faire c'est à dire que les
signalements sont regardés avec
bienveillance
ils sont ils vont jusque dans le détail
je me souviens du cas d'un étudiant
accusé à tort il a été de fait blanchi
et les victimes peuvent s'exprimer sont
prises en considération et peuvent
justement obtenir gain de cause et en
tout cas imaginer qu'il n'ya pas
d'omerta donc je serai je regrette hélas
qu' il soit emporté avec les événements
pour ne pas avoir été suffisamment
solide dans sa ligne de défense et pour
avoir été disons le prisonnier
intellectuellement d'un milieu qui très
clairement était coupable de solidarité
et il en est la victime
quand même la deûle et les trois points
vous donner ces trois pins qui
l'accablent vous êtes en défense mais
son milieu son milieu fait que c'est un
universitaire qu'il est tout à fait au
courant donc la façon dont il est vous
dites leur deuxième chose il aurait pas
dû donner cette leçon inaugurale mais
son milieu fait qui s'est entouré de
marc guillaume et de d'un avocat qui lui
disait a aucun problème alors qu'il
savait très bien par aurélie filippetti
qui avait un énorme problème donc là
vous ne dites il est ballotté
après dans sa défense pas du tout ils
l'organisent parce qu il est de ce
milieu parce qu'il est intelligent parce
qu'il est entouré de gens qui lui disent
ok on va passer en force
ils pensent ils pensent sincèrement et
c'est pour ça que je trouve son
communiqué très bien qui peut mentir
réellement mentir par deux fois il est
pris en défaut et c'est ça qui change
c'est que ce manchon se fait qu'il est
obligé de démissionner et c'est une très
bonne chose mais ces trois éléments qui
vous vous mettez pour sa défense moi
c'est des trois éléments qui l'accablent
il n'aurait pas dû faire comme ça mais
ballotté c'est à dire qu'ils essayent
d'inventer des choses qui ne sont pas
vraies pour se défendre c'est scandaleux
de la part d'un responsable ainsi au
niveau d'une école qui prépare
effectivement les étudiants pour des
responsabilités cc c'est impardonnable
plus vous allez dans ces trois arguments
plus il me semble ne défend pas j'essaie
d'expliquer ce que je crois être une
erreur et ce que je crois être tout de
même une décision que lourdes de
conséquences pour un homme qui n'a pas
commis de faute pénale et voire
peut-être même pas de faute morale c'est
là où nous divergeons puisque je le
signe qu'il n'y a pas de mensonge
je voudrais dire deux choses la première
c'est qu'il ya une phrase de lucho dire
que j'aime beaucoup qui dit on surestime
la méchanceté des gens et on sous-estimé
leur bêtise et je crois malheureusement
on voit souvent un mensonge
michel rocard en avait une autre c'est
face à l'as au complot à la connerie
privilégier la connerie le complot deux
ans
l'intelligence mais c'est pour ça que je
crois qu'il n'y a pas eu même séché les
gens très intelligents dans les cercles
de pouvoir il ya souvent une
impréparation et une forme de nervosité
qui en portent beaucoup de qui fait
sauter beaucoup de digues que
l'intelligence on entendrait plus froid
que l'intelligence les retenaient
premièrement deuxièmement pardon mais je
n'ai pas vu qu olivier duhamel étaient
mis au ban de la société depuis 2008
tous ceux qui savaient tous ceux qui
savaient continue et qui à le mettre à
la présidence du siècle qui à le mettre
sur des plateaux télé où il professait
de son nom donne une leçon inaugurale
ici c'est bien parti si c'était un péché
véniel c'est un péché mais c'est un
péché véniel au regard de la notabilité
conserver conforter mise en exergue par
l'ensemble d'un milieu donc fredericlyon
expie a sans doute à juste titre pour
l'ensemble d'un milieu qui a continué à
bâtir la statue d'olivier duhamel
jusqu'à ce qu'elle soit fracturé par un
ouvrage voilà il me reste deux minutes
juste je voudrais vous faire part de ce
commentaire de jacques julliard dans le
figaro de début février 1er février nous
dit la sphère olivier duhamel une bombe
à fragmentation je veux retenir trois
aspects alors lui aussi là trois aspects
parents d'importance croissant dans
l'ordre politique la fin de la gauche
caviar me dit il dans l'ordre éthique la
naissance d'un nouvel ordre moral dans
l'ordre anthropologique une forme de
résistance de la nature aux furieux
assauts de la culture sur le là là pour
le coup j'étais tout à fait séduit par
la démonstration je la reprends à mon
compte il met beaucoup d'intelligence au
beaucoup sur cette cette histoire là où
il ya énormément de
d'intention criminelle d'utilisation
peut-être de la gauche un moment mais
baissé il y as est un crime ils
l'organisent ils menacent les deux
enfants quand il est menacé dans livre
de camille kouchner en disant si jamais
tu parles
ta mère va en payer les concessions va
se suicider et moi aussi donc il ya
quelque chose ou là toutes les
explications de jacques julliard sauf le
respect que je lui dois sont plus
intelligentes
il ya une phrase de qu'une des rats que
six il va exactement dans votre sens qui
dit il y a beaucoup de romanciers qui se
croient plus intelligent que leur livre
parce qu'il m'a heurté dans cette
histoire c'est que l'écart à la norme à
la normale acceptable on peut imaginer
que dans certains sur certaines
personnes un peu fruste sait il le
découvre chez un professeur de droit
chez un homme aussi éminent il savait
l'écart à la norme et donc je reviens
sur la dernière phrase de jacques julia
effectivement la nature résiste à la
culture
les gens me dire que les vils instincts
de l'homme résiste à la culture y
compris lorsque la culture est quand
même très pro est imminente et très mise
en avant et ce sera la conclusion de ce
match des idées merci à tous les deux
dit avoir participé
c'est la fin de cette émission se
retrouvent demain à 18 heures et à 22h30
comme tous les jours pour un nouveau
numéro d' allons plus loin
en attendant comme tous les jours aussi
vous retrouvez bonjour chez vous dès
7h30 au rayonnement de chimie recevra
notamment julien bayou secrétaire
nationale d'europe écologie les verts je
vous souhaite une excellente soirée sur
public sénat
[Musique]